getting the whole thing in picture is a
bit of a challenge the Elbphilharmonie
or the Philharmonic Hall in Hamburg is
110 metres high mahmood nah it took a
bit of courage to build it but it's
great kind of the sea in the top it's it
seems right really hard to do in a
really good nice architecture there the
idea is to feel connected to water the
lower half of the building used to be a
dark warehouse something quite unique
but it took much longer to construct
them was originally planned I just heard
that it is has been it was supposed to
be open like three years ago the small
items were doing porn was it really is
strange that something like this has
been built here for so much money those
funds could have been used somewhere
else the prestige project was ten times
more expensive than budgeted these
Hamburg taxpayers are trying to stay
positive despite the massive costs via
ham yet Scott Canton bizarre we just got
tickets for the grand opening we're
hoping to be impressed by the concert
hall and the supposedly fantastic
acoustics course it's not about money
anymore right no it's pretty reasonable
74 million euros turns into 780 million
it is a bit odd justice young or normal
banana pretty much everyone in Hamburg
is a little bit worked up about it some
of the local tour guides have taken to
peppering their tourist trips with
cutting commentary well in Papua the
toilet paper holders in this building
cost 300 euros each I mean what makes
them so special do they have Wi-Fi or
something for me the worst thing is that
it's supposed to be our new city
landmark as a handbook by myself I say
we've got one already on the right there
you can see it at 132 meters tall our
lovely st. Michael's Church or as we
locals call it mission but who knows
maybe he will change his mind when the
Elbphilharmonie finally opens its doors
to the public